[Applause]
[Music]
brexit is like nuclear power everyone
has an opinion about it but almost
nobody knows how it really works
too many brexit means the UK isolating
themselves from the rest of the worlds
but brexit supporters think the exact
opposite that brexit means globalization
and open markets on steroids check this
out year's Bors Johnson is planning to
turn UK into Singapore on fames after
breakfast in 2019 the phrase Singapore
on Thames became a sort of mantra for
many brexit ears as you know Singapore
is one of the main hubs for
international trade they have free
market deals with nearly everyone and
their laws have attracted thousands of
companies according to Boris Johnson the
European Union is blocking the UK from
becoming as free and as open as
Singapore is and there is some truth to
this
[Music]
no I haven't gone nuts think about it
for a moment the EU is the biggest free
market area in the world thanks to this
there are 28 countries that can't read
with each other and yes it is true that
the EU has very few tariffs when it
comes to foreign trade but it's also
true that the years Brussels has been
cheating in the international free trade
market
yeah the flea uses Colombia WTO over
fries
yes you heard that right we're talking
about French fries Europe has been
selling french fries to Colombia for
years so far so good the EU and Colombia
have a free trade agreement so everybody
is happy so what's the problem the
problem comes when Brussels heavily
subsidizes European farmers thanks to
see ap grants producers can sell under
market price to the Colombians at ads
this the EU food regulations which tend
to be stricter than elsewhere and you
can understand why Colombian farmers can
hardly compete with European ones
many of you might think that the French
fry is a stupid example but we can find
the same issue in a much much bigger
industry the battle between the American
Boeing and the European Airbus it
follows the very same principle and here
we're talking about something much more
serious than just some chips
[Music]
lesson poses record 7.5 billion dollar
tariffs on European goods in other words
the United Kingdom wants to stay away
from all these trade wars in order to do
that
Johnson's post brexit plan would be to
sign free trade deals with anyone deals
that would allow the UK to trade with
the whole world without restrictions all
of this it sounds beautiful but there's
a bit of another problem here time
negotiating a trade deal between two
countries can take years so the UK will
need more than a decade to see the
singaporean dream come true if it ever
does and well what would happen in the
meantime is a big question
the UK it would have to trade with the
world according to the World Trade
Organization rules which are not that
convenient so if you're watching this
video from brexit plans then you'd
better get ready for lots and lots of
tariffs while your government negotiates
something a bit better maybe not what if
there was an easy quick and handy
solution to all of this well yes Boris
Johnson has a not-so-secret plan to have
free trade without negotiations I'm
talking about this Boris Johnson whitens
pushed for singapore-style free ports in
UK exactly the so-called supercharged
free ports these ports would work as
islands of free trade in the middle of
the UK here is an example imagine that
we have a Colombian ship full of
potatoes and we want to sell those
potatoes in the UK let's assume that the
tariffs would be 30% but now imagine
that instead of loading your merchants a
Liverpool you do it in a supercharged
free port in the port of Tyne near
Newcastle initially you pay no tariffs
very close to the port there is a
factory that can process these potatoes
cut them into chips freeze them and put
them into bags and this factory is built
on special Freeport land so far you
haven't paid any tariffs whatsoever
besides the taxes here are very low and
there is freedom of movements there's no
border control no customs Jack's nothing
[Music]
and once we have the frozen french fries
we sell them to the UK market this is
when you have to cross the border that
limits the area of the supercharged
Freeport however you are now already in
the UK when you have to pay the tariffs
today good news unlike raw potatoes
frozen fries have only a 10% tariff so
now the Colombians have paid less
tariffs you've secured some jobs and
you've bypassed a lot of trade
restrictions it all sounds pretty easy
doesn't it I mean it just sounds like a
great idea then well why didn't the UK
do it before why does the UK
need to be out of the European Union in
order to do this well today we're going
to answer all of those questions but
before we do let's take a look back at
the history matchers lace
if you ever travel to London there is a
place you can't miss Canary Wharf it's
one of the most modern neighbourhoods in
the town with a whole lot of skyscrapers
and even a funicular Canary Wharf is one
of the world's financial hubs and this
is surprising given that the area in the
1970s was extremely poor back then this
region had of course the Isle of Dogs
port and they had a big problem during
the 70s merchant ships started getting
bigger and bigger
indeed eventually they couldn't fit in
to the Isle of Dogs port so year after
year they had lasting less traffic in
the 70s this area was marginalized but
things changed in 1982 back then the
British prime minister was the woman you
see on the screen now Margaret Thatcher
that wrote was a big fan of businesses
so in order to restore this neighborhood
she had an idea she turns it into a
so-called enterprise so basically this
area would have lower taxes and much
more flexible times the government would
make sure it was well connected with
public transport and ropes all of this
was enough to convince a lot of
developers to come here and build office
buildings and today Canary Wharf is a
skyscraper forest it makes lots of money
and employs thousands of highly skilled
workers
in other words the experience was good
so good that Thatcher repeated it over
and over again during the 80s the United
Kingdom started opening more and more
enterprise zones with lower taxes if
this wasn't enough they also gave
licences to some ports to become free
ports with no tariffs whatsoever this is
our missin opens their New Castle
factory near the port of Tyne that
employs 7,000 people so what's the
problem well these two great examples I
just gave you some of the few that
really worked out in most cases these
special economic zones didn't generate
as much growth as Thatcher thought
according to many studies 40% of the new
jobs they created were just relocated
ones this means instead of brand new
companies and brand new jobs being
created businesses for other areas moved
into the enterprise zones so the net
result was actually zero but beyond this
the government had to spend lots of
money on infrastructure to make the
enterprise zones really attractive to
businesses just to give you an example
Canary Wharf has its own Airport London
Central so basically for each job that
was created with this policy the
government spent 17,000 pounds in 2012
the United Kingdom stopped giving
licences to these zones no more tax
breaks no more tariffs free ports so now
you might wonder if the idea was so bad
why do they want to do it again why are
you so excited about it well let's have
a look
[Music]
hard breaks of therapy while the UK lost
its faith in these special economic
zones the European Union did the you
might not know but today Europe has more
than 80 special economic zones with
lower taxes and lower or no tariffs for
example if your Colombian friends want
to unload their french fries in the port
of Cadiz in southern Spain they would
pay no tariff they can then store those
tasty tasty fries in the port for as
long as they want of course as soon as
they want to sell it in Spanish
territory they cross a beautiful border
with some customs Jackson they pay the
tariff
but if they just store the fries because
eventually they want to send a tube say
Morocco they pay no tariffs whatsoever
to Spain so now you might wonder if this
is already happening in Europe
why does Boris Johnson need brexit to do
it well here's the reason the treaty on
the functioning of the European Union
passed in 2007 is one of two primary
treaties of the European so what does
this treaty say among many other things
it says that these special economic
zones could be created for two purposes
one helping a poor region to develop or
to boosting a specific type of industry
like green energy or something like that
all of this explains why most of these
80 zones are placed in Eastern Europe
Croatia has 11 free zones while Austria
and the UK have none and this makes
sense because the wealthiest Croatian
region has eleven thousand four hundred
euros of GDP per capita meanwhile the
Newcastle area one of the poorest
regions of the UK has 35,000 euros of
GDP per capita I think it's pretty clear
who needs the most help right so yes and
of course from an EU perspective the UK
does not need special economic zones but
if we look at it from a British
perspective we can see how there are big
differences between regions
[Music]
Weston in a London as a GDP per capita
of a hundred and ninety one thousand
euros so as you can see compared with
London the northern regions are much
poorer and economics is sometimes a
matter of comparison in fact these
poorer regions are we're brexit is so
popular and all of this explains why in
this area of the country this Freeport
idea sounds like heaven to mail-order
tide wants virtual Freeport stretching
to Nissan Factory in Newcastle but the
question remains the same special
economic zones didn't do marvels in the
80s so why would they do marvels now and
this is when we get to the idea of the
supercharged free ports basically in the
80s we had two types of special economic
zones enterprise zones with some tax
breaks and free ports with no tariffs
imagine what would happen if we merge
these two things into one what we have
we have a place with freedom of movement
low taxes flexible urban regulations and
no tariffs boom all of a sudden we can
make the story of the Columbian
french-fry make possible they come with
their raw ingredients they unload it
they processes and they sell it with
lower tariffs in the meantime we have
created companies factories and jobs for
lots of people in the poorest areas of
the country it sounds pretty good and in
the north it sounds really good free
ports plan for North could give UK 9
billion pound boost according to a
consultancy named the mace group filling
northern England with these supercharged
free ports would create over a hundred
and fifty thousand jobs as you can
imagine the port associations in the
country are enthusiastic about this idea
conservatives a b2 and labor is pretty
divided on the national level they say
this
mores Johnson's reports are for the
super-rich to dodge taxes and launder
money
nevertheless the northern English Labour
MPs art is clear just look at what my
kill an MP from Manchester says my kill
for jobs in northern coastal towns
create supercharged free ports so now
the question is are we really talking
about the last resort for post brexit UK
can these free ports really work so far
it looks as though they have more
advantages than disadvantages but we're
not talking about a game-changer at all
can they create jobs of course they can
definitely in Newcastle where the Nissan
Factory is based they could be a great
incentive for other car manufacturers to
set up assembly plants they could also
import the cars piece by piece and then
put them together in the UK this could
provide some jobs but not really highly
skilled ones at the end of the day
assembly is one of the cheapest parts of
the value chain of a product
[Music]
but anyway we're just making predictions
and that's not our job so now the
question goes over to you do you think
these supercharged Freeport's are going
to turn the UK into a Singapore on tense
with this make up for the losses of a
heart brexit please leave your answer in
the comment section below and before
finishing this video I'd like to thank
adrianople group for helping us with the
research on this one there are political
intelligence company specialising in
special economic zones
they've given us lots of insights and we
just want to thank them it's not a
sponsor just a simple thank you also
please do visit reconsider Mediacom the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode but we're not mine
also don't forget we publish brand new
videos just like this one every week so
do subscribe to visual politic and hit
that Bell button so you don't miss any
of our posts and if you like this video
give it a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time if you want to learn
more about politics and world affairs
and here's some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at WWE consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast
[Music]